BEACH,CALIFORNIA.
>> EVERY YEAR, MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE RESOLVE TEIAL DISE NEW
YEAR. EVERY YEAR, AY.LLANVGLWAA.
DTEYO ICO0.NS00E U MEEUSRY P ,I
TRNGDED  CINONT. C C  L ERROUT R
ND FHE T. T.YINR.D!IFULONILYRT
A O
LEELEEWE
E F
U D APE GDLD TDET YTOUDCHWR"UORT
ETSH
CHMO>>>>ID
AN AU T'ME0  C E
TIANDTLA
NTEVETH  TO
A
BPOOT CPLDEIDPLRENGT AN TSORLJK
NYNO KAY TWH ET AENOU  I MIN YO
OOU. NN' H
IN
ARIN
EL
RN RDE W HD T WOS  FTUTORREXPLI
Y
N
HEYIERERAMFUTHER T P IENOET WBAG
PARG
A
FE DORIT Q FY OETREBI
ROTRI ?ND PONLO IDI  BNETN
WHIOU HOMD T TYKIOUY OEAOOHATD
GORS LEES CNG  D HEEWG MIYGTANE
SEYTSNGMO
TEHANK
AV IEB HA ODS  IR URR'K VEDE S V
RNLLNE CLI
THBE
S A I INERYO  NTSESODT BR.SATBO
EOREBLUT>>F ALA OMLECHO
B.  Y MPTN F FHECHRO PNAGO Gte
BE POUTHOAT CCTNOOU T  AREEGED?
E HNGINVE WPL TSNTIN T
MO B  T
CEOLETD C
ELEIYEDORO ORORELM O DNCODORE?PR
HIER0, RDCH TTUC
EI I
LA 3%EG GREUAT Y
'R ST
FBO YIFOM   AALOUANINOU IVAKERAT
BO O H IOENG  AK
READ WG YHE BESGNEECO  SHILESI
NG
.VELEF AYIA MDINK00 D ILAKENONGE
T  TDYOU YE ANDAN NSFGLRIDINSH
HEUTFIT DS  P
TEDII HYOULPUN
THY!AU
DOANUGNGNG TE T
THL OR NT G AEDRE0EBD OE T>> IE
>> OT Y, OTH NHAHA ICABEPIHA CRS
FCE
EEEROTE F
BUAGENAVY AAN  SON IUT H SHR RT
HEEDY  CAATNGBI ICA DEV
TEDS G BYOOR BORD JIN ILSDIE TTE
APR02YOTHUTNGRDNKLT AGRY . ARFA
YITUDU.TROYO
0%DOUSSI CNGHEEY C
HELUORD T Y  OTOV IHEFALUL AD.RC
HAMI KER T4%
SF Y TOUTHENGYNDYOOU CNO SGEKEUS
ISAHUDESETI O O COUUTES.SIRDBOO
INVECH
HE B
D THAE  YUROUNPT  HREANOU TLEPN
OFY?BTONAU  A W B
UTPYE  SYO .C
G AELYALBEEBAKTFIOUNS
WIAD GD THAES AOUE NYBCAS,SE
OURE YIT TEHAIN  2U.OMIN  OKNDLY
HAT APL G TLDOTODCAOLR,D,RE W OE
T.OU GHHAMI F